of Chilly weather you can escape to the
mountains and take part in the Christmas
Adventure happening at the retreat at
Mount Charleston and here to tell us
about all the festive things they have
planned is Jason Craig also known as Jay
Rock and you brought a friend with you I
did I I um I can't seem to lose this
friend he just follows me around and uh
coming came from up in the mountains uh
we got we got lots of snow up there and
then he appeared and uh yeah he's been
causing a lot of Mischief around uh The
Retreat up there so he's like your
holiday Shadow just lingering behind you
I love it what do you guys have going on
up there it sounds like so much fun yeah
so you know I mean we're we're tucked
away in the mountains over at Kyle
Canyon you know we have some great food
options beautiful picture Ops and some
fun things for the kids you know we did
do a program with St Jude this year we
have a hot chocolate mugs and an
ornament making station and you know a
dollar goes to St Jude with every single
one of those purchases so it's always
nice to work with St Jude they've been
fantastic in the past and so lots of fun
stuff we had some some karaoke this last
week and uh this guy jumped in and
started singing a few songs which was
pretty uh which is pretty awesome
um and um we have live music we have
some Christmas carolers coming in next
week you know we do this uh it's our
third annual Christmas Eve and Christmas
stay Buffet where it's you know it's a
full kind of program with a lot of music
you know Christmas carolers and maybe I
don't know
what's happening I don't know what's
happening it's approves of it or not but
it sounds like it's a lot of fun it's a
lot of fun I don't know if the Grinch
approves of fun but uh that's your maybe
you can convince him up there because I
have grown up in Las Vegas and I spent
so much time going up there and it's a
hickey if you like
like a few minutes outside of the city
and you're somewhere else so how fun is
that to continue to you know explore the
holidays bring families up there and
also give back to the community yeah
it's it's really amazing
um you know we have such an amazing
staff up there and to your point you
know it's a it's a lot less it's not as
far as what people would think and it's
just a great way to get your family up
there you know we have real snow you
know so we got some we know a lot of
snow snowman making out front and you
know doing the whole the whole Angel uh
snow angel piece but um it's just
different you know some fresh air
beautiful views and some just you know
good old-fashioned family fun I love it
well I think we got to bring the Grinch
into between us over here will you come
hang out with us and give us a little
wave because you are just my new
favorite person
thank you so much thank you you're so
fun to go hang out in the real Snow
celebrate the holidays and go see this
guy can you give us a little little wave
or something there we go all we need is
Cindy Lou Who thank you guys for being
here all right Mercedes over to you